cosmic horror it isn't the typical scary
stuff about a fear of dying or evoking
some kind of physical terror but an
existential crisis made manifest the
idea that we as humans have no purpose
whatsoever essentially making our lives
our very existence meaningless turned
into a monster h.p lovecraft is often
cited as the originator or at least
popularizer of cosmic horror in all of
his fictional texts he explores the
theme resulting in some pretty
terrifying plots like in at the mountain
of madness where humanity's existence is
revealed to be an accidental result of a
scientific experiment by aliens
then there are his original monsters
there are fungal beings who appear as
winged clawed carapace-covered creatures
shapeless protoplasmic bubbles made of
iridescent black slime and the most
notorious a tentacled cosmic giant
cathedral
cthulhu is the old one's high priest who
can help humans liberate themselves from
the constructs of morality to shout and
kill and revel and enjoy themselves in a
destructive revelry of ecstasy and
freedom
lovecraft may be cthulhu's inventor but
the creation has outgrown its originator
impacting both the horror genre and real
life in significant ways
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
cthulhu's head is a pulpy mass of
tentacle-like feelers resembling an
octopus its rubbery grotesque body is
covered in scales its back has
rudimentary narrow wings and long talons
adorn its hind and forefeet
described as part dragon part octopus
and part human this monster is so
bizarre so terrifying it drives anyone
who sees it mad in lovecraft's universe
cthulhu is a leader or holy figure akin
to a priest and one of the great old
ones an extraterrestrial species that
inhabited earth long before humans
called it home the old ones and cthulhu
aren't really gods per se
after all god is a human construction
but they serve as symbols of unknowable
cosmic forces while the old ones are no
longer physical beings on earth they
cannot die so calling them dead doesn't
quite work they lie awake in the dark
ever watching hidden under the earth's
crust and beneath the ocean's depths and
can still be contacted they are
considered a lost culture although some
parts of lovecraft's world continue to
worship the creatures the old ones
continue to communicate with humans
telepathically and could be physically
evoked through rituals but only if the
astral alignments are just right
the notorious cthulhu first rose from
the depths of the ocean from a sunken
city called rilje in lovecraft's short
story the call of cthulhu
originally published in the february
1928 pulp magazine weird tales
the call of cthulhu is told from the
perspective of narrator francis weyland
thurston who investigates the strange
records left by his recently deceased
great uncle in the story that started
the legacy cthulhu is never encountered
physically by a character seen only in
dreams and artwork
lovecraft's inspiration for the story
came years earlier in a dream about a
man exploring a museum of antiquities
when lovecraft returned to the idea he
woven elements from his current life in
providence rhode island including real
addresses and even a documented
earthquake he also found inspiration in
pre-existing literature
like the invisible mind manipulating
presence at the center of french author
guide mel pissant the horla as well as a
merits the moon pool arthur manchins the
three imposters and w scott elliott's
atlantis and the lost lemuria i also
have to mention that lovecraft wrote
extensively about how much he hated
eating seafood and fish which makes
those tentacles in horror from the ocean
themes seem a lot more intentional
lovecraft grew up during the second
industrial revolution when the increased
presence of railroads automobiles
electrical power telephones and other
rapid industrial advancements
contributed to urbanization
commercialism and cultural development
all around not to mention environmental
impacts
lovecraft asked his readers to consider
what would happen if our impact was
taken away or made meaningless
for fans of lovecraft today it may come
as a surprise that for nearly two
decades after his death in 1937 he was
widely dismissed as an untalented writer
by critics and public audiences alike
his works were viewed as nothing more
than fodder for young adults and
eccentrics although some would argue
similar sentiments today
born in providence in 1890 his father
died of syphilis in a mental asylum and
he was raised by his mother and maternal
family members from a young age
while intelligent he was an avid reader
at age three he was also a high school
dropout his literary career began in
1914 as a journalist although he quickly
expanded into fiction his influences
were vast and included gothic literature
historical travelogues greek classics
romantic literature scientific
discoveries of the 19th century and his
own agnostic beliefs and ancestral
history after a failed marriage in his
30s their separation partially a result
of his xenophobic and anti-semitic
beliefs his wife sonia was the daughter
of jewish russian immigrants he lived
with his aunts his own published work
never produced a livable income
he used his inheritance and skills as a
copy editor and ghost writer to survive
lovecraft's lifetime marked a period of
transition in the united states
as the country attempted to come into a
cohesive identity amid the first world
war changing views of sex and women's
rights the spread of socialism new
scientific discoveries and increasingly
booming immigrant population
all of these themes and the anxieties
surrounding them are present in his work
despite some of these now outdated
opinions lovecraft's influence on other
writers and creators of all kinds is
extensive
enough so that it can be a challenge to
even locate all the references to his
works especially because lovecraft used
overlapping narratives sticking
references to his own creations into the
text he was ghostwriting and encouraging
other authors to reference his universe
in their own books characters towns and
even monsters appear in world as a
collective tradition commonly called the
cthulhu mythos the term cthulhu mythos
was coined by lovecraft's author friend
august durleth the first person to
collect and publish lovecraft's short
stories in one volume under the arkham
house publishing company some argue that
the success of lovecraft's cthulhu
mythos is at least in part made possible
by the habitable worlds he created
stories were often set in seemingly
realistic spaces new england towns for
instance whose physical characteristics
character genealogies and histories are
crafted with such detail they feel real
to the reader even cthulhu possesses
just enough recognizability it is a
non-supernatural monster who is both god
and extraterrestrial but its appearance
contains enough physical real world
markers like the octopus comparisons
that its existence seems plausible
but still very very scary
cthulhu is an eldritch being a weird
eerie sinister force
the etymology of the word eldritch can
be traced back to monsters elves more
specifically originating in the scottish
language the term applies to those
things that resemble or suggest elves or
supernatural beings invocating
associations with the weird the foreign
the strange and the uncanny cthulhu is
considered extraterrestrial and no doubt
a monster cthulhu and the great old ones
force humanity to reconsider their place
in the world lovecraft's creatures are
not malevolent just indifferent at least
to humans
some scholars and fans even argue that
this is where much of the horror of
lovecraft comes from
we are disturbed by the fact that not
only are we inferior but that the beings
older and wiser than us simply don't
care about our existence
the concept of eldritch post hp
lovecraft is inherently tied to what is
generally believed to be a modern
invention cosmic horror
this unique form of spooky is an
extension of the gothic and nihilism
where terror arrives from that which
reminds us that we not only cannot
comprehend everything in the universe
but that those things are inherently bad
part of cthulhu's history is outlined in
the necronomicon an invented mythical
work supposedly penned by one of
cthulhu's devotees that lovecraft
references in many of his stories
it outlines the origins of the old ones
lovecraft initially claimed the
necronomicon was translated from a
real-world arabic text a playful
allusion to the romantic gothic genre
where other fictional origins of text
became a common trope he would later
admit that the necronomicon text never
existed lovecraft himself called it
synthetic folklore keep in mind
lovecraft's original text that included
mention of the necronomicon
are intentionally vague while some
passages have been incorporated into his
stories there was no full manuscript
anyone could base a book on so people
made one up in the 1970s physical copies
of the necronomicon were published by an
author under the pseudonym of simon
although it borrowed more from sumerian
mythology hoax versions of the text
still pop up from time to time
considered a religious text a cult book
or demonic grimoire depending on the
audience lovecraft's entirely fictional
book of the dead became a real world
participant in the cthulhu mythos there
are real people who worship cthulhu and
even crimes have been committed in the
name of the so-called religious text not
all of lovecraft's influences are so
serious however the necronomicon plays a
key role in the evil dead franchise pops
up and jason goes to hell and appears in
many comics
in the 1980s lovecraft and his most
famous creations were introduced to a
much wider audience with the production
of the role-playing game call of cthulhu
which was basically about your character
going insane video games have also been
based on cthulhu mythos
there are even kid-friendly versions of
cthulhu like plushies baby books and
school gear the cute interpretations
literally soften the monster's
grotesqueness and encourage playful or
even protective behavior rather than
existential terror and i for one would
love to know how the author would feel
about cute cthulhu especially given its
commodification while lovecraft is
considered a prolific and significant
author of the 20th century it is
undeniable that much of his fiction
reflects his real world racism while his
xenophobia might have been more
acceptable during his lifetime it's
jarring for the modern reader
modern texts like lovecraft country ring
shout and the ballad of black tom deal
with the racist and misogynistic
tensions in his texts head-on crafting
new additions to the cthulhu mythos that
are still applicable to our world today
humanity has come a long way from what
the world looked like when lovecraft was
alive but the contemplation of our role
in the universe or lack thereof is still
at the forefront of our minds
history lovers we need to tell you about
a new series from pbs called the bigger
picture hosted by professor vincent
brown it's a show that examines famous
photographs and unpacks the historical
context around them
in doing so we reveal what these photos
can tell us about our history but also
how we view ourselves check out the
first episode at the link in the
description and head to the pbs youtube
channel to see it for yourself tell them
monstrum sent you
lovecraft's original text that included
mention of the necronomicon
why am i changing up the vowels
in the 1970s physical copies of the
necronomicon